[Musique]
chez les shadoks rien de nouveau ils
pompaient toujours mais plus ils
pompaient pompaient pompaient plus leur
moral baissait baissait baissait
et malgré les efforts du professeur
charcot épuisé tombé par milliers alors
le chef shadoks flanqué de son fidèle
sorcier fait venir château cos et lui
parla en ces termes et il le fit mettre
au groupe
[Musique]
il faut dire que le groupe était une
sorte de trou dans lequel on entassait
les shadoks qui n'avait pas donné
entière satisfaction
on l'appelait aussi quelquefois en faire
à cause que ceux qui étaient dedans y
était enfermée
comme les jib il avait prévu le plan
shadow karaté le cosmo gun est revenu
les hippies se dépêche de rentrer de
vacances ont font le plein de le refuser
si bien qu'en moins de rien ils sont
prêts à partir pour la terre tout est-il
perdu pour les shadows peut-être pas car
le sorcier veillées et attendait son
heure
[Musique]